to convene a
[Music]
on the third sunday third of april for
monday at 3 p.m and then an emergency
meeting which we requested
at 12 o'clock on the 4th of april
after you refused our first request we
the second time uh issue a decision that
wasn't coordinated with anyone that it
would be better to discuss this topic
today this is
an outrageous situation
uh set up my
letter to you yesterday as an official
document of the council i would like to
ask you on what basis
you
feel that you can act in such an
outrageous way
existing norms and rules don't you know
that that in case you don't agree with
our proposal you should have convened
these meetings and so
forward
the issue of the advisability of holding
a meeting or vote
especially since you should have had
before you the example of our presidency
where we didn't refuse a single time
any of the six meetings in ukraine
we demand an
explanation from you and we hope that in
the future you will not challenge the
right of members of the security council
to request the uh
meeting
enshrined in level two
of the security council at the request
of any member of the security council
so there he was thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation
is there anyone else who wants to
comment on this i will uh explain
the presidency's position in just a
moment
okay
if i could um respond to your points
uh
from the russian federation we did uh
not reject your request for a meeting we
received your letter
on sunday and it is the responsibility
with the obligation of the presidency to
schedule a meeting
you particularly requested a meeting for
a time on monday
our proposal as presidency was to
schedule the meeting either alongside
the meeting today so well within the 48
hour limit which is the convention of
the security council
or to hold the meetings sequentially one
after the other and i understand that
the russian federation turned down both
proposals but i wish to be clear that we
did not reject the request for a meeting
the deferral proposed was uh less than
24 hours
and
to be clear
we share the view that this is an urgent
situation
and we have as i say offered the russian
federation either a separate meeting
today or to combine it with this one and
so as far as the presidency is concerned
uh we did
everything in line with the provisional
rules of procedure
and with precedent we have received no
other complaints from council members on
the subject
i give the floor to the russian
federation
24 hours before the meeting that we
requested
this is uh
confirmed documentaries in documents if
anyone is interested we can provide
proof but i want to express that oh it's
just because i didn't
i thank the representative of the
russian federation uh the presidency
will not refuse to host meetings uh in
the future uh and i hope that that now
closes that point and we can proceed
with the adoption of the agenda
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is letter dated the 28th of february
2014 from the permanent representative
of ukraine to the united nations
addressed to the president of the
security council s slash 2014 slash 136
the agenda is adopted
should like to start by
taking the opportunity to pay tribute on
behalf of this council uh to her
excellency lana nasa the permanent
representative of the united arab
emirates
for your service as the president of the
council for the month of march
i'm sure i speak for all of us
in expressing our deep appreciation to
ambassador sabre and her team
for the skillful conduct of the
council's business last month thank you
very much indeed to your team
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the representative of ukraine
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
on behalf of the council i welcome the
participation of his excellency mr
vladimir zeliensky the president of
ukraine
and just add that as usual precedent the
permanent representative of ukraine will
also join the meeting in case of any
technical issues
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
miss rosemary de carlo under secretary
general for political and peace building
affairs
and mr martin griffiths under secretary
general for humanitarian affairs
emergency relief coordinator
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i also invite his excellency mr
olofskoog head of delegation of the
european union to the united nations to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
[Music]
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
i wish to warmly welcome his excellency
the secretary general his excellency mr
antonio gutierrez and i give him the
floor
madam president
excellencies
the war in ukraine
is one of the greatest challenges ever
to the international order and the
global peace architecture founded on the
united nations charter
because of its nature
and consequences
we are dealing with the full-fledged
invasion on several fronts one member
state of the united nations ukraine
by another the russian federation a
permanent member of security council
in violation of the united nations
charter
and with several aims including
redrawing the international recognized
borders between the two countries
the war has led to senseless loss of
life massive devastation in urban
centers
and the destruction of civilian
infrastructure
i will never forget the horrifying
images of civilians killed in butcher
and i immediately called for an
independent investigation to guarantee
effective accountability
and i'm also deeply shocked by the
personal testimony of rapes and sexual
violence that now are emerging
the high commissioner for human rights
has spoken of possible war crimes grave
breaches of international unitarian law
and serious violations of international
human rights law
and the russian offensive has also led
to the displacement of more than 10
million people in just twenty months
the fastest forced population movement
since the second world war
far beyond ukraine's borders the war has
led to massive increases in its pride in
prices of food
energy and fertilizers because russia
and ukraine are linchpins of these
markets
it has disrupted supply chains and
increased the cost of transportation
putting even more pressure on the
developing world
many developing countries are already on
the verge of debt collapse due to the
impact of the kov 19 pandemic and the
lack of adequate liquidity and debt
relief
stemming ultimately from the unfair
nature of our global economic and
financial system
for all these reasons it is more urgent
by the day to silence the guns
that is why ask the emergency leave
coordinator martin griffiths to travel
to russia and ukraine to press for an
urgent humanitarian ceasefire
and the secretary general griffiths will
update you on the humanitarian situation
and the results of this contact so far
and the secretary general di carlo will
also brief you on the political and
human rights dimensions
but secretary general united nations it
is my duty to call the attention of the
council
to the serious damage being done to the
global economy and particularly to
vulnerable people and developing
countries
madam president
our analysis indicates that 74
developing countries with a total
population of 1.2 billion people
are particularly vulnerable to spiking
food energy and fertilizer costs
depth obligations take up some 16 of
developing countries export earnings
and in small island developing states
the figure is 34 and rising
because of increased interest rates and
the need to pay for expensive imports
in the past months alone which prices
have increased by 22
miles by 21
and barley by 31 percent
brent oil prices on the first of april
were more than 60 percent higher than at
the same time last year
a series of events have led to that not
only the present situation
natural gas and fertilizer prices more
than double over the same period
we are already seeing some countries
move from vulnerability into crisis and
signs of serious social unrest
the flames of conflict are fooled by
inequality deprivation and underfunding
with all the warning sign of signals
flashing grad we have a duty to act
madam president the global crisis
response group on food energy and
finance that i set up last month
has formulated some initial
recommendations for the consideration of
member states international financial
institutions and others
on food
we are urging all countries to keep
markets open resist unjustified and
unnecessary export restrictions and make
reserves available to countries at risk
of hunger and famine this is not a time
for protectionism humanitarian appeals
must be fully funded
people crop up in crisis around the
world cannot pay the price for this war
our on energy the use of strategic
stockpiles and additional reserves could
help ease this energy crisis in the
short term
but the only medium and long-term
solution
is to accelerate the deployment of
renewable energy which is not impacted
by market
fluctuations these will allow the
progressive phase out of coal and other
fossil fuels and renewables are already
cheaper in most of the cases
and on finance international financial
institutions must go into emergency mode
we need urgent action by the g20 and
international financial institutions to
increase liquidity and fiscal space
so that governments can provide safety
nets for the poorest and most vulnerable
the reform i've been calling for the
global financial system is long overdue
all these actions are closely linked
with the prevention agenda and with
building and sustaining peace
madam president the war in ukraine must
stop now
we need serious negotiations for peace
based on the principles of the united
nations charter
this council is charged with maintaining
peace and doing so in solidarity
i deeply regret the divisions that have
prevented security council from acting
not only on ukraine but on other threats
to peace and security around the world
i urge the council to do everything in
its power to end the war and to mitigate
its impact both on the suffering people
of ukraine and on vulnerable people and
developing countries around the world
and i thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
remarks
i now give the floor to ms roshmiticalo
thank you madam president since i last
briefed this council on 17 march the
security situation in ukraine has
seriously deteriorated
the number of ukrainian civilians killed
has more than doubled
ukrainian cities continued to be
mercilessly pounded often
indiscriminately by heavy artillery and
aerial bombardments
and hundreds of thousands of people
including children the elderly and the
disabled
remain trapped in encircled areas under
nightmarish conditions
the devastation brought on mariupol and
other ukrainian cities citiz cities
is one of the shameful hallmarks of this
senseless war
the horror deepened this past weekend as
shocking images emerged of dead
civilians some with hands bound lying in
the streets of bucha the town near kiev
formerly held by russian forces
many bodies were also found in a mass
grave in the same locality
reports by non-governmental
organizations in media also allege
summary execution of civilians rape and
looting insure naheef harkeef and kiev
regions
madam president away from the fighting
diplomatic efforts to end this war
including direct talks between ukrainian
and russian representatives have
continued
we commend the government of turkey for
hosting these discussions as well as the
efforts of many others engaging with
russia and ukraine to help bring about
peace
we welcome the willingness of the sides
to continue engaging to reach a mutual
understanding
this requires good faith and earnest
efforts
and progress in the negotiations should
be translated quickly into action on the
ground
while there has been a reported
reduction of russian troops in attacks
around kiev and chernihief
such moves should not be merely tactical
repositioning forces for renewed attacks
on ukrainian cities and towns elsewhere
the general assembly has twice called
for russian forces to withdraw entirely
from ukrainian territory and cease all
military operations
we also take note of the reported
withdrawal of russian forces from around
the chernobyl nuclear site
the international atomic energy agency
reports
that this development will hopefully
allow it to conduct an assistance and
support mission to provide technical
advice and to deliver equipment where
necessary as soon as possible
all nuclear sites in ukraine must be
fully protected and secured military
operations in around these locations
must be avoided
madam president
the numbers tell a tragic if yet
incomplete story
according to the office of the high
commissioner for human rights
at least one thousand four hundred and
eighty civilians have been killed and at
least two thousand one hundred ninety
five injured between twenty four
february and four april twenty twenty
ohchr believes that the actual figures
are considerably higher
we are gravely concerned by the
persistent use of explosive weapons with
the wide impact area in or near
populated areas
such weapons are causing most civilian
casualties as well as massive
destruction of civilian infrastructure
including residential buildings
hospitals schools water stations and
electricity systems
ohchr has received credible allegations
that russian forces have used cluster
munitions in populated areas at least 24
times
allegations that ukrainian forces have
used such weapons are also being
investigated
as noted by the high commissioner
indiscriminate attacks are prohibited
under international humanitarian law and
may amount to war crimes
the massive destruction of civilian
objects and the high number of civilian
casualties strongly indicate that the
fundamental principles of distinction
proportionality and precaution have not
been sufficiently adhered to
in besieged cities a significant
increase in mortality rates among
civilians can also be attributed to the
disruption of medical care and basic
services
people with disabilities and the elderly
are particularly vulnerable
as of 4 april 2022 the world health
organization has reported a total of 85
attacks on health care facilities
resulting in at least 72 fatalities
and 43 injuries
madam president we are seriously
concerned about reports of cases of
arbitrary arrests and enforced
disappearances of persons who have been
vocal against the russian invasion
as of 30 march ohchr has documented the
arbitrary detention and possible
enforced disappearance of 22 journalists
and civil society members in kiev
hairsun luhansk and zapparia regions
24 local officials have also been
detained in regions under russian
control
13 of whom have been subsequently
released
we call for the immediate release of all
individuals who have been arbitrarily
detained including journalists local
officials civil society activists and
others
also as of 30 march ohchr has recorded
seven journalists and media workers
killed since hostilities began
another 15 have come and come under
armed attack nine of whom were injured
allegations of conflict
related sexual violence perpetrated by
russian forces have also emerged these
include gang rape and rapes in front of
children
there are also claims of sexual violence
by ukrainian forces and civil defense
militias
the u.n human rights monitoring mission
in ukraine continues to seek to verify
all these allegations
we're also concerned about disturbing
videos depicting abuse of prisoners of
war on both sides
all prisoners of war must be treated
with dignity and full respect for their
rights in accordance with international
humanitarian law
madam president the many credible
allegations of serious violations of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law from
areas recently retaken from russian
forces must not go unanswered
we support efforts to examine these
allegations and to gather evidence
ensuring accountability and justice for
acts committed during the war will not
be easy but it is essential
madam president we are heartened by the
generosity of neighboring countries who
accepted millions of refugees and the
solidarity of the ukrainian people who
are hosting their displaced compatriots
with more than 10 million people
displaced either within ukraine or
abroad as refugees
roughly one quarter of the population
the united nations is gravely concerned
about the heightened risk of human
trafficking
indeed
suspected and verified cases of human
trafficking are surfacing in the
surrounding countries according to the
international organization for migration
madam president this war is devastating
ukraine now
but it also threatens its future
early assessment projections by undp
suggests that if the war continues
through 2022
ukraine faces the prospect of seeing 18
years of socio-economic progress lost
this would set the country and the
region back decades and lead deep
long-term social and economic fissures
un agencies including undp are working
to help preserve ukraine's hard-worn
development aims gains
this involves supporting the government
to sustain
essential government structures and
basic services including emergency
measures to sustain livelihoods such as
cash-based assistance
madam president the war in ukraine has
damaged europe's security architecture
its economic repercussions are already
evident far from the battlefield
the longer the war continues the greater
the risk that it will further weaken the
global institutions and mechanisms
dedicated to preserve peace and security
the war was started by choice
there is no inevitability to it or to
the suffering it is causing
the united nations is ready to do
everything when its means to help bring
an end
to it thank you madam president
i thank mr carlo for her briefing
and i now give the floor to mr martin
griffiths
thank you madam president um as you've
just heard from
the secretary general and under
secretary general dicarlo
ukrainian civilians are paying
far too higher price for this war
i want to speak briefly about
humanitarian needs and what we're doing
to meet them before i then
refer to my recent travels
in the last six weeks as we have heard
at least
1430 people have been killed among them
over 121 children and we know this is
very likely a serious underestimate
homes and civilian infrastructure
bridges
hospitals
schools
have been damaged and destroyed
and in fact the current figures on
displacement
tell us that more than 11.3 million
people have now
been forced to flee their homes and of
that 4.2 million in our refugees
in those generous neighboring countries
that rosemary has just been referring to
so in total more than a quarter of the
population of ukraine has fled
in this extraordinary
a short time
unfortunately we can imagine that these
figures will continue to rise until we
can find
a pause
and some peace madam president
the ground and air offensives and
counter offenses
are making life nearly impossible for
many civilians in ukraine families the
elderly women and children have been
trapped by fighting already for too long
for more than five weeks
the people of mariepole have been caught
up in the fighting
and it is well documented that really
maripola is a center of hell
other cities like chernahev sumi
remain cut off from essential goods and
services
and perilous conditions are hampering
our efforts to access civilians or for
them to access us
and we restate here that civilians must
be allowed to move
to safer areas without the fear of
attacks
and at their own choice and at their own
selection
it's vital that all parties
uh to the conflict respect their
obligations under international
humanitarian law to protect civilians
and to allow impartial humanitarian
organizations safe
rapid unimpeded access to all civilians
in need wherever they are
in ukraine
madam president as the world watches
humanitarian needs saw in ukraine
the united nations
and our partner organizations
are making every effort to dramatically
increase our support to affected
civilians
the work of the 6 000 volunteers
from the ukraine red cross as we have
noted before in this chamber together
with local ngos in eastern ukraine
these
people these organizations continue to
work tirelessly tirelessly at the front
line of assistance to communities
the world food programme has reached
more than 1.3 million people with cash
and food assistance and plans to push
that number up to two and a half million
people in this month
health partners report
that more than 180 tons of medical
supplies were delivered in ukraine
with another 470 tons
on the way
and this will address the health needs
of about 6 million people
in the months ahead
and i'm pleased to say that seems an odd
word to say in the context
of ukraine that after much effort in the
past day another convoy
went from our humanitarian hub in
dinipro
to the far east
today food winter clothing
non-food items medicine
hygiene kits were offloaded to the
ukraine red cross
and will reach the hands of those most
in need
indeed following notification
to both parties a formal process
that we and also the international red
cross are engaged in
four convoys in total from the un
have provided critical support to people
in some of the cities encircled by war
where on with and affected by ongoing
fighting several more are planned
so these are initial steps
but it gives us a basis to now expand
and taking our efforts up to scale and
expanding much more than one convoy a
day
as the secretary general and the under
secretary general's already said
i want to also join them
in expressing my concern over the
growing number of reports we receive of
human trafficking sexual violence
exploitation and abuse in ukraine and in
the region
and as there are such horrific incidents
as we are seeing
there overwhelmingly impact displaced
women and children more than others
we are bolstering protection and
gender-based violence services
through agencies to provide specialized
care for survivors
and through the the
the wealth of civil society
organizations in ukraine
these services are designed carried out
directly in collaboration with and
through ukrainian civil society
including
very particularly women-led
organizations
madam president today i'm addressing you
from geneva
having just returned from moscow
overnight
as you know the secretary general as he
said
charged me to bring both sides together
on humanitarian grounds to explore both
specific
and sustained ways to reduce
humanitarian suffering including in
particular
uh into aliyah but in particular the
pursuit of the humanitarian ceasefire
yesterday in moscow
i had long and frank exchanges with the
minister of foreign affairs sergey
lavrov
and his deputy sergei roshinin
and then separately
with alexander fuhrman the deputy
minister of defense
in my meetings
with these senior officials
i discussed also in addition
to these
possibilities of evaluation and
ceasefires
i discussed the issue of humanitarian
convoys of safe passage
including the four which we've i've
already referred to
i outlined possibilities for building
further on that cooperation
sharing specific suggestions for
mutually agreed upon military freezes
to allow for evacuation of civilians and
for the safe passage of life-saving aid
in effect for humanitarian pauses in
different parts of ukraine to save lives
and bring back a modicum
of
safety for those living in those places
my counterparts in moscow received these
suggestions assured me of their intent
to carefully study those ideas which i
left with them
and we agreed to remain in close contact
and i came away from these meetings
believing that we have a very long road
a long road ahead of us
but it must be traveled
the melon president we will travel it
tomorrow i hope to travel i plan to
travel to ukraine
to have discussions with senior
authorities
from the ukrainian government
in kiev on thursday on these same issues
and others that they will no doubt
present to me and also to see firsthand
with our crisis coordinator amin awad
the humanitarian response
madam president
thanks to generous
donor contributions
many from governments
in this chamber the humanitarian
response since february
has indeed been scaled up allowing us to
meet the needs of one and a half million
people
we will need sustained financial support
for needs in ukraine
and like the secretary general i want to
stress
as he has done consistently that funding
must not be diverted from other crises
and madam president
to afghanistan that is one
as you heard from david beasley last
week
conflict climate shocks poverty
compounded by the soaring food and fuel
costs
indicated by the secretary general
could push another 47 million people
globally into severe food and security
and so the total number of people around
the world who will not know where their
next meal comes from
could be driven
to the astonishing figure of
325 million people around the world
that is by a long distance the highest
in our recent history and well over
double
what was what it was three years ago
so madam president i close of course
like others by reminding the council of
what the council already knows well
the world cannot afford this war
and neither can the people of ukraine
and like others i call on all council
members and member states with influence
to support all efforts from whatever
part they come from in the pursuit of
peace
and the alleviation of humanitarian
suffering for the sake of the people of
ukraine
for the sake of those around the world
who cannot afford to bear the additional
burden
this war imposes on them
and all of us we must as the secretary
general said
silence the guns thank you madam
president
i thank mr griffiths for his briefing
i now give the floor to his excellency
mr vladimir zelinski the president of
ukraine you have the flaws there
thank you very
much members of the security council and
other members of this meeting thank you
very much for this opportunity i'm sure
that all the representatives of the
united nations member states will hear
me today yesterday i returned from
foreign
is
women
wars and deliberately lead them in uh
such a way that to kill as many
regular
civilians and cities to
leave the country
where they deploy their troops
with
global food crisis that could lead to
famine in africa asia
and other countries and will
surely end in large political chaos in
many countries
uh
but the world has yet to see what they
have done in other occupied cities and
regions of our country
geography
might be different of various but
cruelty is the same crimes are the same
and accountability must be inevitable
ladies and gentlemen i would like to
remind you of article one
chapter one of the year
what is the purpose of our organization
its purpose is to maintain peace and
make sure that
peace
is violated literally starting with the
article 1.
since the end of world war ii and they
are being committed russians troops are
deliberately destroying united ukrainian
cities
to ashes by with artillery and
airstrikes
right
they are deliberately creating
conditions in the temporarily occupied
territories so that as many civilians as
possible are killed there
the massacre in our city
is only one unfortunately
ukrainian communities
each of
them is similar to buddhism
i know and you know perfectly well what
the representatives of russia will say
in response to the accusations of these
crimes they have said that many
boy times donbass by russian forces with
russian weapons or during the war in
syria they will blame everyone just to
justify their own actions
that is what we are interested in
maximum access for journalism maximum
cooperation with the international
institutions involvement of the
international criminal court complete
truth and full accountability
i'm sure that everything
those who consider themselves privileged
and believe them
then everyone
our people russia has already deported
hundreds of thousands of our citizens to
their country they abducted more than 2
000 children you just simply constructed
that those children and continue to do
so russia wants to turn ukraine into
silent slaves
the russian military are looting openly
the cities and villages
this is wide scale
looting they are doing everything
is
so they are destroying everything that
they can yeah
is
received
and then perhaps there would not be war
in my country
against our great
against ukrainian people again
our citizens but the world i mean
and did not want to see
and wars near their borders
how to start
the russian military
and those who gave them borders
it's time to transform the system
and integrity of states and
it is countries clear that the goal
in san francisco in 1945 for the
creation of a global security
international
organization
and it is impossible to achieve them
without
with the ability to respond preventively
to security challenges and thus every
delivery peace prevent aggression and
force aggressors
have the determination and ability to
punish if the principles of police are
violated
there can be no
ukraine
of the main is
updated security system
similar to the geneva office that deals
with human
rights that deals with environmental
protection
people
was
would come
decisions from the security council for
peace in ukraine
if you do not know how to
uh
to make this decision you can do two
things
either remove russia as an aggressor
to establish peace or
the option is
to show how we can
um
watch this short video
please give us one more minute of your
time
one country
it with your own eyes therefore i would
ask you to watch this video thank you
very much
uh
[Applause]
they have the video
is it just coming
so they have it in their position
i we
will sort that one out uh technically we
don't have the video um so i propose
that while we sort that out
i thank his excellency mr zeliensky for
his compelling and powerful remarks
we will come back to the video when
we've sorted out the technical uh
the technical issues around it
and may i say speaking in my national
capacity may i express appreciation to
the president uh for his leadership in
wartime and for the extraordinary
fortitude and bravery of the ukrainian
people under this unprovoked and illegal
invasion
i resume my function as the president of
the security council and while we sort
out the
technical video i propose to give the
floor to those council members who wish
to make statements
and i now give the floor to the
representative of the united states
thank you madam president
let me also start by thanking uae and
ambassador nisabe for her successful
presidency during the month of march
madam president
as you begin
your security council presidency i want
to thank the united kingdom for your
leadership and for organizing this vital
discussion on ukraine today
i also want to thank the secretary
general for his remarks
and the other briefers
and i'd like to extend a warm welcome to
president zielinski
i was so moved by the address he made
recently to our congress
and we are truly honored by his presence
here under the circumstances
that he and ukraine face today
madam president last night i returned
from a trip to moldova and romania
i saw with my own eyes the refugee
crisis caused by russia's unconscionable
war
i spoke to refugees who indicated to me
their desires to return to their home
and we've all seen the images on tv of
the bummed out buildings
but what we have not seen
is that behind those destroyed buildings
are destroyed lives
and destroyed families
i met with women and children who had
fled ukraine who stuffed their lives
into backpacks and left the only home
they had ever known
and these were sobering conversations
one young woman i spoke to came with her
six-year-old brother
who had autism and is struggling with
cancer
their single mother helped them escape
to save their lives
but russia's war has interrupted the
care her brother desperately needs
another woman i spoke to
fled with her eight-year-old from odessa
the father
who they'd left behind
told them they were shelling right next
to their apartment that very night
and they very well could have died had
they not
left
a third woman i met
told me that she used to love to travel
but never expected her next trip would
be to flee her life
flee for her life
when i asked her where she was from
she started to say and then she stopped
with tears in her eyes and said i'm
sorry
i don't know how to say it whether i
live in kiev
or whether i used to live in kiev
she was realizing in the moment
just how dramatically her life had
changed because of this senseless war
these are three stories of more than 10
million
people
6 million internally displaced 4 million
who have left ukraine all together
4 million people who have relied on the
big-heartedness of countries like
moldova romania poland slovakia hungary
and others across the region in the
world to welcome and support
all those leaving ukraine
in search of safety
ukraine's neighbors are bearing the
brunt of europe's most significant
refugee crisis since world war ii
and i want these countries to know that
they have a committed partner
in the united states
and that is why the united states
announced recently that we are prepared
to provide more than 1 billion u.s
dollars in new funding toward
humanitarian assistance for those
affected by russia's war in ukraine and
its severe impact around the world
and it is why we are welcoming up to a
hundred thousand ukrainians and others
fleeing russia's aggression to the
united states
we will continue to assist humanitarian
efforts to help the people of ukraine
and all those fleeing putin's violence
but as heart-wrenching as the stories
are that i heard in moldova and romania
there are some stories
we will never get to hear
those of the people we saw in the images
out of bucha
we've all seen the gruesome photos
lifeless bodies lying in the streets
apparently summarily executed
their hands tied behind their backs
as we work to independently confirm the
events depicted in these images
i would remind this council
that based on the currently available
information the united states has
assessed
that members of russia's forces have
committed war crimes in ukraine
and even before seeing the images from
bucha
president zielinski along with others in
the region were reporting that children
were being abducted and we heard him say
that today
also abducted are mayors and doctors
religious leaders journalists and all
who dare defy russia's aggression
some of them according to credible
reports including by the mayoral polls
city council have been taken to
so-called filtration camps
where russian forces are reportedly
making tens of thousands of ukrainian
citizens relocate
to russia
reports indicate that russian
federal security agents are confiscating
passports
and ids
taking away cell phones and separating
families from one another
i do not need to spell out what these
so-called filtration camps are
reminiscent of
it's chilling
and we cannot look away
every day we see more and more how
little russia respects human rights
and that is why i announced yesterday
that the united states in coordination
with ukraine and many other u.n member
states will seek russia's suspension
from the u.n human rights council
given the growing mountain of evidence
russia should not have a position of
authority in a body whose purpose
whose very purpose
is to promote
respect for human rights
not only is this the height of hypocrisy
it is dangerous
russia is using its membership on the
human rights council as a platform for
propaganda to suggest russia has a
legitimate concern for human rights
in fact we will hear some of that
propaganda here today i know
and i will not dignify these lies with a
response only to say that every lie we
hear
from the russian representative is more
evidence that they do not belong on the
human rights council
140 u.n member states voted to condemn
russia over its unprovoked war and the
humanitarian crisis it has
unleashed
upon the people of ukraine
here's my message to all of you
now is the time
to match those words with action and
show the world that we can work
responsibly
and i share president zielinski's view
that this moment requires responsible
world powers and global leaders to show
some backbone
and stand up to russia's dangerous and
unprovoked threat against ukraine and
the world
the secretary general said that
confronting this threat is the security
council's charge
it is
and it is also the responsibility of u.n
leaders and leaders around the world
every single member state with a voice
in the ga
no one
can be a shield for russia's aggression
suspending russia from the human rights
council is something we
collectively have the power to do in the
general assembly
our votes can make a real difference
russia's participation on the human
rights council
hurts the council's credibility
it undermines the entire u.n
and it is just plain wrong
let us come together to do what is right
and do right
by the ukrainian people
let us take this step
to help them to start to rebuild their
lives
and let us match the courage of
president zielinski who we are so
honored to have with us today
president zielinski
i want you to know that we stand with
the people of ukraine
as you face down this brutal attack on
your sovereignty on your democracy and
on your freedom thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement and i give the
floor to the representative of albania
thank you madam president
let me thank basido lucibe for having
steered our work during the month of
march and wish the uk a new madam
president
full success in our common work during
this month
albania welcomes president zelinski
presents to this meeting
his remarks are painful and his account
on what ukraine is experiencing under
russian occupation is revolting
we stand by you mr president
by your compatriots all ukrainians for
their heroic resistance for the
resilience that the entire world is
admiring
you are not alone
you have the world on your side because
it's the is the side of the right
of the just and as we hope of victory
slavokrani
madam president let me thank sg
gutierrez for his again very clear and
powerful remarks
i also thank usg dicarlo and griffiths
for their updates
this is the 14th meeting of the security
council on ukraine since the 31st of
january while the war of aggression has
entered the second month
let's establish a few basic yet
meaningful facts
russia has stalled and its imperial
dreams are nowhere
taking ukraine finally proved impossible
kiev was too hard to swallow
russian army is in disarray but it has
not stopped shelling and bombardments
but all this is not new and all this is
not news
the real news that has horrified the
world is what russia is leaving behind
the unspeakable horrors those
soul-crushing images in areas from which
russia is withdrawing
images of civilian executed with a
bullet in the neck
sometimes with their hands tied behind
their backs or shot dead in their
bicycles
images of mass graves overflowing with
corpses
images of carnage and devastation
including looted homes rape and sexual
violence
acts usually attributed only to thugs
they spring from the same cruel impulses
as the bombardment of cities homes
hospitals schools and kindergartens by
the russian forces
butcher is an open air graveyard
the notorious facelift of the russian
aggression
madam president we have heard
time and again
it is not russia
yes but no
it will be hard actually impossible to
convince anyone that the destroyed tanks
that clutter the roads
the mines and booby traps left behind
amid the wreckage and the bodies of
civilians killed by arbitrary executions
and laying in the streets amidst the
breeze
are staged scenes for propaganda
who would believe that russia aggressed
ukraine simply to protect civilians
while ukraine is busy staging horror
movies
you make muzzle media back home
but you cannot fool satellite images you
cannot blind independent reporters and
human rights ngos on the ground
waiting for russia to accept and tell
the truth
is waiting for god to arrive
and he never does
these are facts hard and sickening proof
of the atrocities committed the ugly
face of this madness
such crimes as documented by human
rights watch and verified by independent
and respected professional reporters
those who are banned for the russians
call for answers
call for thorough investigation for
effective accountability for justice
prime minister rama called these crimes
a terrible pain and a horrible shame
russia has an international obligation
to abide by international militant law
the laws of war including the geneva
conventions of 49 and its first
additional protocol
russia has an obligation to abide by the
order of icj to immediately hold this
military activity in ukraine
but unfortunately russia has made
another choice
not to respect any of it
and has cancelled itself from
international law
but the law will pursue it
russian army and its commanders cannot
escape
accountability the name of the butcher
of maripool
a criminal that has reduced an entire
city to ashes
and has made its citizens go from three
meals a day to barely three meals a week
is engraved in the ruins of the city
this is why we will support the call to
suspend russia's participation in the
human rights council
the unga resolution that created the
council stipulates that and i quote
members of the council will respect the
highest standards in the promotion and
protection of human rights
as we see
russia's standards are nose eating and
its presence there is a first
a desecration of the place that is
called to be the sanctuary of rights
dear colleagues
russia has announced that it will now
shift its focus on eastern ukraine this
means that it will concentrate its
brutality there
in what may end up becoming a war of
attrition
russia has blocked the renewal of the
osce international
observer mission in ukraine
this denies the international community
the independent eyes it needs there
this anticipates
sadly more war
further atrocities other crimes even
more humanitarian disasters
this war continues to particularly
affect women and children millions have
been displaced many of them alone in
search of safety and security it is
heartbreaking to see mothers write names
and addresses in the back of their
children
so that they are recognized in case they
end up being orphans
we welcome the efforts of ocha and its
partners to deliver assistance in
support of the people in ukraine and the
millions of refugees in neighboring
countries
madam president let me end with this
note
rarely has the outcome of a war been so
disastrously the op the complete
opposite of what it wanted to achieve
russia's army has been defeated by the
outgunned and outnumbered ukrainian
resistance
russia is isolated like never in its
history
it has become the world's most
sanctioned country in history
no country has ever seen itself
transform in a matter of only 10 days
from a global player into a financial
and international pariah
to the point that it is obliged to find
comfort in the support from north korea
and syria
dear colleagues
this aggression is and its startling
defeat have once and for all separated
the fates of ukrainians and russians
because the case of ukraine is also the
cause of democracy against tyranny and
kleptocracy
it is a fight between the will of the
people against the will against the
vicious will of one
whose reckless actions have challenged
everything we stand for and who is
directly responsible for the economic
disruption and food insecurity which is
affecting the entire world
he may choose to stop
withdraw troops and quit ukraine
or continue to descend in the very abyss
he has created and faced the
consequences
i thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for his statement i understand that we
now have solved the technical problems
so i suggest we return to the video
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i
would like to
thank
the delegation of ukraine
for
sharing
uh that video with us
the images are harrowing
speaking in my national capacity
we are appalled
by what we have seen
and reiterate our solidarity with
ukraine
i resume my function as the council
president
and i now give the floor to the
representative of gabon
anthony
respective briefings
participation i welcome the
participation in this speech
madam president we continue that we
continue to i guess powerless
[Music]
my country is very
concerned as well as attack
attacks against
humanity and humanitarian personnel
humanitarian workers working in theaters
of conflict should never be the target
yes
yes they are very often the link between
them
and what remains of humanity when the
rug has been said
humanitarian workers should be able to
file humanitarian assistance to wherever
it is
without obstacles and in conditions of
security
guaranteed by all parties
should be possible to foreign
in living conditions indeed survival
conditions
are very concerning
especially when civilian infrastructure
and provision of essential
public services
we are concerned
the elderly
all parties should abide
foreign
[Music]
as soon as possible to shed light on the
victims and uh
is
all persons
them to ensure respect for their dignity
and we call for failures
it is
there is no other way
and for the guns to be silenced thank
you
i thank the representative of gabon for
her statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of the russian
federation
gratitude to the
delegation of the united arab emirates
[Music]
better than anyone else he should know
the efforts that russia is undertaking
every single day to organize
humanitarian corridors
however
the arrangements reached with the help
of
international mediators
is consistently not being uh implemented
by the ukrainian side
you're going to
overload you with figures
such communiques are published every
single day by our ministry of
without any participation by the
ukrainian side we have managed to save
one hundred twenty three and a half
thousand people
whoops
over 600
000 people have been evacuated to russia
including over 119 000
the voluntary decision by these people
is testified by many uh
videos that are
accessible in social media
another topic of meeting those declared
today which
is practically not being discussed today
so i'm going to uh point that out i
simply would like to
take advantage of the virtual presence
here of the uh president of ukraine and
would like to uh address
him directly
[Music]
accusations against the russian military
which are not confirmed by any
uh any eyewitnesses and we spoke about
this in detail yesterday at our press
conference
alexander which we do all remember that
when in 2019 we were elected as the
president
including the russian-speaking
population which you pledged to protect
verge of correcting the historical
injustice when as a result
uh
ukraine began to be transformed into a
hateful anti-russia and that seemed to
be on the verge of being turned that
page of being
turned
into
as a subspecies
who in fact threatened that uh the
residents of the donetsk and lugansk
will rot in their basements
representatives
inquisition in a country where russian
is the native language for a minimum
forty percent of the past
explosions
over the entire territory of ukraine
preparing already back in march to solve
the problem of the donbass
in the course of our special operations
we have found many secret orders
testifying to this
nazis
in the ukraine however we know very
quickly
that not only are they there but
unfortunately they are running the show
they got more how can they go in their
way
hundreds of thousands of peaceful polls
russians ukrainians and jews
not to notice ukrainian nazis
uh pretending
nazi greetings and they're open about it
in the social medias
and they're killing like this
the civilians which they use as human
shields and
position uh
position heavy artillery next to
residential buildings and multiple iraqi
adventures as well
today we've heard once again a huge
amount of lies about russian uh soldiers
in the military
we have hundreds of
thousands of video testimonials of
people
ready to provide testimony
these are cruel histories but you need
to hear them
and it robbed civilians at checkpoints
basements anyone trying to leave
is
[Music]
they
uh by soldiers with blue armbands those
are ukrainian insignias
is
school
intentionally targeted
and ukrainians tortured
themselves
this is absolutely unacceptable the fact
that you even consider that russian
ukrainian civilians who were killed by
their own radicals in the best
traditions
i'm talking about youtube performance i
understand that
corpses and her testimonials but you saw
what they showed you
you couldn't ignore the flagrant
inconsistencies
which is confirmed by several people
is
have i've been calling black white and
vice versa
it's simply a pawn
against
is
[Music]
we came to you
is
raising
that are needed
[Music]
it might be too late soon thank you very
much for your attention
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement and
i now give the floor to the
representative of ireland
thank you very much madam president and
i'd also like to thank the secretary
general and our other briefers this
morning
i want to express a very warm welcome to
president zielenski being with us this
morning president zielenski
your courage
your leadership
and the courage of the ukrainian people
are an example to all of us
secretary general on the 24th of
february as russia launched a
large-scale invasion of its neighbor
ukraine you told the world that russia's
action was wrong
that it was against the charter that it
was unacceptable
we agreed with you however you also told
us
that this invasion was reversible
and called on president putin to end
this war to save innocent lives
we echoed those calls
sadly 40 days later
our call has been left unanswered
instead
over the last 40 days
we have witnessed unprecedented levels
of destruction
and human suffering
we are watching cities pounded by
russian artillery we are seeing millions
forced to flee their homes
seeking refuge from russian aggression
just minutes ago here in this chamber
we have seen the utterly shocking images
of civilians lying
dead in the streets of butcher and
elsewhere in ukraine some we know are
piled into improvised mass graves
simply harrowing
so many innocent lives lost on our watch
as our pleas for peace go unheeded
the attempts here today
to deny russian culpability are frankly
appalling in their cynicism
and i see them as an insult to the
memory of those slaughtered civilians
madam president we roundly condemn the
atrocities reportedly committed by the
russian armed forces in a number of
occupied ukrainian towns
the images from bucha and other towns in
the kiev region liberated by ukrainian
forces
are horrifying
we here cannot suspend our humanity our
thoughts first and foremost must be with
the families of those killed
their pain at the loss of their loved
ones in such an unspeakable manner
is almost unimaginable
let's be clear
the russian authorities are responsible
for these atrocities committed while
they had effective control of the area
the russian authorities are subject to
the international law of
occupation there can never be impunity
from such crimes
never ever
not in bucha not another any other town
or village
ever
for crimes have been committed they must
be fully investigated and evidence
preserved so that these crimes can be
prosecuted by domestic and international
courts including the international
criminal court
ireland will continue to support efforts
to ensure robust and independent
investigation of all violations of
international law
we must have accountability
and justice for the victims
and for the survivors of this war
we at this table share that
responsibility in face of such atrocity
we call on the russian federation to
abide by the order of the international
court of justice and to immediately
cease its military action and withdraw
from the entire territory of ukraine
madam president in the last 40 days we
have seen a horrific humanitarian
disaster unfold in ukraine because of
the russian federation's unprovoked and
unjustifiable further invasion of that
country
a country where just weeks ago
citizens lived in relative peace and
prosperity and one which has been
transformed now into one where families
lack access to basic necessities
where basements have become bob shelters
where millions millions have become idps
and refugees
the use of explosive weapons in
populated areas has had a devastating
impact on civilians in the midst of
active hostilities
once again we call for the parties to
the conflict to comply with
international humanitarian law
including the obligation to direct
attacks only against military objectives
the prohibitions against indiscriminate
and disproportionate attacks and the
obligation to take all feasible
precautions in attack
we have heard increasing allegations of
sexual violence by russian soldiers
you referred to this this morning
secretary general
we must stress that conflict-related
sexual violence can constitute a war
crime
the perpetrators of such crimes must be
accountable
they must be held accountable they will
be held accountable
sexual violence is another abhorrent
crime of this war that cannot go
unanswered
we again reiterate the need for full
safe and unhindered humanitarian access
to those in need as called for today by
martin griffiths
secretary general we again echo your
call for russia to implement an
immediate humanitarian ceasefire
is the very least the aggressor can do
it is way past time
as we know
the reverberations of this war
are reaching far beyond ukraine
it's unacceptable that russia's war of
choice against ukraine is also having
and will continue to have significant
spillover effects across the globe
deterioration of food security surging
energy prices increasing poverty
the most vulnerable and impoverished in
developing countries will suffer the
most
we utterly reject that
madam president it is our collective
responsibility here at this table to
maintain international peace and
security
nothing less
this is why we call on the russian
federation to stop this war
to stop its unlawful attempts to
establish
occupying authorities to stop
destabilizing
the democratic foundations of the
ukrainian state
such steps are yet further reprehensible
violations of ukraine's independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity
it gets harder each time to say this
but it is never too late to do the right
thing and to end this war now thank you
madam president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement and i now give the
floor to the representative of brazil
thank you madam president
let me start by thanking ambassador
along with her team at the uae mission
for competitive competently navigating
the work of the security council in
march
i welcome his excellency mr vladimir
zelinsky president of ukraine
in the council today
i would like to thank the secretary
general antonio guterres
and the secretary general for political
affairs rosemary dicarlo and i'm the
secretary general for humanitarian
affairs martin griffiths
for their updated presentations about
the situation in ukraine
madam president
as we enter into the sixth week of
hostilities in the ukrainian territory
we continue to witness appalling images
of human suffering
the recent reports of acts of violence
against civilians
in bucha erpin kharkiv donetsk and other
places affected by the conflict are
extremely worrying
according to the statement by the icrc
we call for a really independent and
thorough investigation
of all reported violations
with the full cooperation of both
parties to the conflict
without prejudging any conclusions
and underscore the need for perpetrators
to be held accountable
the international community is
witnessing for too long appalling scenes
of destruction of once peaceful cities
with shocking images from the conflict
and the desperation of thousands of
civilians trapped in the battlefield
with no food
no water and no electricity
once again
we renew our pleas for a broad effective
and immediate cessation of hostilities
in ukraine
only after the silence of the guns and
the withdrawal of troops
are achieved will it be possible to halt
the immense costs of human suffering
this conflict has brought
madam president
the general assembly has recently
adopted a resolution
on the humanitarian situation in ukraine
as we said on that occasion
the general assembly could not become a
bystander of the shocking consequences
of the conflict
and
as we added last week in this chamber
neither
can the security council
has the main u.n organ with primary
responsibility
for the maintenance of international
peace and security
the security council has the mandate
and the responsibility
to address the situation in an effective
manner
nevertheless
our assessment is that the security
council is failing in its role to help
in supporting efforts to foster a
constructive dialogue between the
parties
with the aim of brokering an effective
peer settlement
to this conflict
we deeply regret that the security
council has not been able to speak with
one voice throughout the crisis
promoting compliance with international
humanitarian law
protecting civilians
calling for peace
these are objectives that should unite
rather than divide us
we should strive to create the
conditions for on the one hand
invigorating the political negotiations
and on the other
reaching an understanding on practical
measures to minimize human suffering in
ukraine
civilians wishing to flee the
hostilities
must be able to do so in safety
and those who decide to stay
cannot become targets of attacks
in the same vein
parties must grant safe passage to
relief consignments to those in need
once again brazil reiterates the call
for all parties to fully respect and
ensure respect for international
humanitarian law
the causes of conflict whatever they are
do not undermine the obligations of all
parties have to guarantee that civilians
should be protected
that the wounded receive medical care
that humanitarian assistance reach those
in need
and that detainees be treated humanely
in all circumstances
there must be no politicization of
humanitarian actions
nor selective application of
international humanitarian law
also
geopolitical objectives must not
supersede the endeavor for peace nor
prolong the human suffering
caused by war
madam president
this conflict and its associated
sanctions
apart from the enormous human suffering
and devastation
caused in ukraine
is having spillover effects in the
entire world
especially through increased prices of
oil gas grains and fertilizers among
others
food insecurity has become an even
greater threat to the world's poorest
people
above all in developing countries
the longer this conflict persists
the higher the risk of further
instability hunger and devastation in
ukraine
and around the world
it is high time
to return to the path of dialogue and
diplomacy
for a peaceful settlement of the
conflict
we urgently need the cessation of
hostilities
de-escalation of tensions and
negotiations are the only way out of
this conflict
not only for the countries directly
involved but also for the entire world i
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of brazil for
his remarks and i now give the floor to
the representative of kenya
oh thank you madam president
i congratulate you on assuming the
presidency of the security council for
april and assure you of my delegation's
full support
i listened closely to the remarks by the
secretary general
and his under secretary general rosemary
dicarlo and martin griffiths
hoping to hear that our fears that the
war in ukraine has entered a new
more dangerous phase were exaggerated
sadly they offered no such comfort
instead we are left with the words of
his excellency volodmir zelensky the
president of ukraine
who has described the horrifying
suffering of civilians in butcher and
other towns and neighborhoods in ukraine
his account of the atrocities
is in stark contrast to that of our
colleague in the security council the
representative of the russian federation
but the fact that the truth in butcher
is contested
is the surest sign that we stand on the
precipice of more widespread abuses of
human rights
in april 1994
even as genocide engulfed rwanda there
were members of the security council
contesting the horrifying truth that a
million people were being murdered
we should stand warned that the
inability of the council
to establish the facts
and accordingly attribute responsibility
may enable the risk of escalation into
far worse crimes
beyond the city of butcher madam
president
we're extremely worried about the safety
of civilians who are trapped in other
besieged cities and villages such as
mario paul
and queson
our actions today should seek to prevent
what we have witnessed happen in butcher
take place
in mariopol and queson
while we debate who is responsible for
the horrors of butcher
it is incontestable
that what started as a special military
operation is now a war
and that what began with reassurances of
limited aims
not targeted at civilians has led to
thousands of dead civilians and millions
of refugees and internally displaced
no one can doubt that they are flagrant
violations of international law
international humanitarian law and the
u.n charter underway in ukraine
kenya condemns the abuses undertaken in
the past few weeks
and those in the eastern provinces of
the country during the years that the
conflict has raged
madam president
the war in ukraine is today's most
dangerous threat to the maintenance of
international peace and security
it is the latest assault
by the most powerful states against the
multilateral order
their continued abuse of the charter
created growing cracks over the years
in the global security order
now the bottom has fallen out
ukraine may now become a model for new
generation of disastrous wars on
multiple continents
millions of refugees are being created
and there will be many more as the
economic effects of the war produce and
intensify conflicts elsewhere
accelerating food and energy prices are
plunging millions into worse forms of
poverty
the u.n as a forum for solutions to
humanity's most pressing problems
is losing prestige and its historical
standing
president zelinski has left us with
ideas for security council reform that
we need to consider seriously
things have fallen apart and the center
cannot hold under these assaults on our
united nations we must reform
there are no easy solutions
even a negotiation
that is not properly structured to
protect the people and sovereignty of
ukraine could be the prelude to a wider
war
for now we urge the following urgent
steps understanding their limits due to
the continued inability of the security
council to act decisively
we call for an impartial and prompt
united nations investigation
into the atrocities against the
civilians in butcher and other towns in
ukraine
this calls for an immediate end of all
hostilities to guarantee unfettered
access by the investigating teams
we urge the conflicting parties to
immediately make clear to their military
personnel that they will be held to
account on the basis of command or
superior responsibility if they violate
the international laws that regulate
warfare
we commend ukraine's neighbors for
opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities from ukraine
we continue to urge them to ensure that
the thousands of affected africans be
treated
[Laughter]
conflict in ukraine
we reiterate our call for the cessation
of hostilities to allow humanitarian
operations under clearly defined contact
lines
and humanitarian passages
madam president i finish by reaffirming
kenya's recognition of the inviolable
rights of ukraine to its sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
independence i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of mexico
senora president president
exit
president
this month
is
recreate it with even
invasion of ukraine
on ukrainian
territory it now falls for the united
nations
in as much as it is
all mechanisms
[Music]
[Music]
protecting the civilian population
[Music]
is
is
as well
[Music]
i thank the representative of mexico for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of india
thank you madam president
let me begin by thanking secretary
general antonio gutierrez
for his presence and remarks on the
situation in ukraine
i also thank usg rosemary de carlo and
usd martin griffiths for their
respective briefings on the security and
humanitarian situation
we thank the participation of the
excellency the president of ukraine at
today's meeting
i also take this opportunity to thank
the united arab emirates and ambassador
lana nusaiba for their excellent
presidency
madam president the situation in ukraine
has not shown any significant
improvement since the council last
discussed the issue
the security situation has only
deteriorated as well as its humanitarian
consequences
recent reports of civilian killings in
busha are deeply disturbing
we unequivocally condemn these killings
and support the call for an independent
investigation
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively to the
humanitarian needs
we support calls urging for guarantees
of safe passage to deliver essential
humanitarian and medical supplies
keeping in view the dire humanitarian
situation in ukraine india has been
sending humanitarian supplies to ukraine
and its neighbors which include
medicines and other essential relief
material
we stand ready to provide more medical
supplies to ukraine in the coming days
india continues to remain deeply
concerned at the worsening situation
and reiterates its call for immediate
secession of violence and end to
hostilities
we have emphasized right from the
beginning of the conflict the need to
pursue the path of diplomacy and
dialogue
when innocent human lives are at stake
diplomacy must prevail as the only
viable option
in this context
we take note of the ongoing efforts
including the meetings held recently
between the parties
the impact of the crisis is being felt
beyond the region with increasing food
and energy costs especially for many
developing countries
it is in our collective interest to work
constructively both inside the united
nations and outside towards seeking an
early resolution to the conflict
allow me to reiterate the importance of
human guiding principles humanitarian
assistance once again
humanitarian action must always be
guided by the principles of humanitarian
assistance just humanity neutrality
impartiality and independence
these measures should never be
politicized
we continue to emphasize to all member
states of the un that the global order
is anchored on international law un
charter and respect for territorial
integrity and sovereignty of states i
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of india for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of china
thank you madam
assuming the presidency of the council
for this month at the same time i would
also like to thank ambassador bay as
well as the uae team
for their outstanding work when uh uae
was the president of the council during
the month of march
madam president de-escalating tension in
ukraine and putting an early end to the
fighting is the urgent expectation of
the international community and the
strong desire of china we have many
times emphasized that dialogue and
negotiation is the only way out for
opening the door of
russia and ukraine have already had
many rounds of negotiations we welcome
the two sides to stick to the general
direction of
peace negotiations overcome difficulties
and differences and continue to build
conditions for a comprehensive
settlement of their crisis
the international community should
create
favorable conditions and environment for
negotiations between the two sides open
up space for political settlement and
should not set up roadblocks to increase
resistance for peace let alone add fuel
to the fire to aggravate confrontations
every effort should be made to prevent
the escalation of the localized conflict
china attaches great importance to the
humanitarian issue in ukraine and
supports all initiatives and measures
conducive to alleviate the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine as the current
conflict continues we call on the
parties to abide by international
humanitarian law protect the safety of
civilians and civilian facilities
minimize civilian casualties
and ensure safe and smooth evacuation
and access of humanitarian corridors
as well as guarantee the basic rights of
women children and wounded violence
humanitarian issues should not be
politicized the humanitarian needs of
ukraine and its neighboring countries
are enormous international humanitarian
agencies should maintain neutral
and impartial
uh should maintain neutrality and
impartiality actively mobilize and
coordinate more resources and make and
remedy efforts to save lives and protect
civilians china has provided and will
continue to provide humanitarian
assistance
and its neighboring countries under
international law civilians should be
spared of any forms of violence in the
armed conflict and attacks against
civilians are unacceptable and should
not occur
you won't put
the reports and images of civilian
debtors in bucharest are very disturbing
and the relevant circumstances and
specific causes of the incident must be
verified and established
and again all accusations should be
based on facts before conclusions are
drawn
parties through the exercise restraint
and avoid unfounded accusations
madam president
by secretary general terrace the spilled
over effects of the ukrainian crisis is
having a major impact on the world and
the developing countries in particular
this requires our great attention
and our strength and management
sanctions are not an effective means to
solve the problem but we'll instead
accelerate the spillover of the crisis
and bring new and continuous proper
further today
with the deep development of
globalization and the closely linked
community of mankind the implementation
of all dimensional and indiscriminate
sanctions is tantamount to politicizing
instrumentalizing and weaponizing the
world economy triggering serious crisis
in the fields of global economy and
trade finance energy food industrial
chain and supply chain
and endangering
decades of development gains of the
international community and making
people of all countries pay a hefty
price
the vast number of development countries
are not practiced to the conflict and
should not be involved in this
confrontation let alone be forced to
bear the consequences of geopolitical
conflicts and great power competition
the world's major economists would be
responsible for managing the risk of
crisis spilled over and maintaining
their stability of global markets and
the momentum of their global economic
recovery madam president
more than 30 years after the end of the
cold war
such a dual political tragedy taking
place of in europe now deserves a
profound reflection the sovereignty and
territory integrity of all countries
should be respected and small and
medium-sized countries should not be
pushed to the forefront of confrontation
between an amount great powers all
countries have the right to decide their
foreign policy independently and should
not be forced to take sides the security
of all countries is inseparable and the
security of one country cannot be
achieved at the expense of the security
of others we call upon the united states
nato and the european union to engage in
comprehensive dialogues with russia to
face head on their differences
accumulated over the years find
solutions to the problem and promote the
building of a balanced effective and
sustainable regional security framework
on the issue of ukraine
china does not seek geopolitical sort of
interest it is not our mindset to watch
the situation indifferently from the
side of the line let alone do anything
to add fuel to the fire
there's only one goal we sincerely look
forward to and that is peace china will
continue to promote peace talks and play
a constructive and responsible role in
helping resolve the crisis in ukraine i
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of china for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of france
um
images of mass
but also crimes against humanity
children is adding the disgrace of uh uh
madam president
is not giving into hatred and rather to
take action along the following months
first of all we need to maintain the
strongest possible pressures to compel
the russians
global security
security well beyond europe including
support
president
humanitarian laws
ukraine who are playing a major role
in receiving refugees the hospitality
that they've demonstrated
to europe the european union has in
particular mobilized
500 million
for the ukraine
to achieve a humanitarian ceasefire to
allow the evacuation of civilians from
besieged cities
all efforts should be made in order
involvement in
by negotiations ukrainian authorities in
seeking the political uh solution once
the ceasefire is achieved as well as by
maintaining the channels of dialogue
the french minister of europe
the day in the face of the horror of the
russian aggression france reaffirms its
solidarity and support for the ukraine
the ukrainian people we also call on the
russian people who are also victims in
this war to continue to find ways of
expressing their opposition to this
in spite
ukrainians and russians thank you very
much
i thank the representative of france for
her statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of norway
thank you president
i thank the briefers for their valuable
inputs
norway
also expressed its ultimate support to
you secretary general to make full use
of your good offices in search for a
peaceful solution
i want to thank president zielenski
through you
ambassador for his strong testimony this
morning
and for the heroic fight
the president the ukrainian government
and the ukrainian people are engaged in
for your country and for the peace and
freedom of us all
we are with you and we support you
as we heard from president zielenski and
i have seen this weekend the need for
peace could not be more urgent
for more than 40 days and nights attacks
from russia have continued to batter the
ukrainian people and their cities
causing death and destruction
and the suffering is escalating
we too are appalled by the reports
coming out of the areas around cube and
other regions
we are deeply shocked by the atrocities
committed against civilians in places
that has been held by the russian forces
including butcher
the images are distressing
dead bodies on the roads and in mass
graves
homes school hospitals and other
civilian infrastructure destroyed
and reportedly left mine
president
russia is desperate to hide the truth
about the war but us atrocities must be
investigated and those responsible must
be brought to justice
in this respect we welcome the
establishment by the human rights
council of a commissioner inquiry on
ukraine
to investigate all alleged violation of
international humanitarian law
and human rights law
and we also welcome that the icc has
opened an investigation into the
situation in ukraine
we urge russia and everyone holding
evidence to fully cooperate with these
investigations
we cannot allow there to be impunity for
war crimes being committed in ukraine
the world is watching
president
russia's unprovoked an illegal war
against ukraine a free and sovereign
country
is also an attack on democratic values
and on freedom it is a blatant violation
of international law and the very
principles of the u.n charter
and as the secretary general on the line
this morning this council has a
responsibility we must do everything in
our power to end the war and to mitigate
its impact
let me repeat the message by the
norwegian prime minister stirrer gave to
president putin when he spoke when they
spoke on thursday
he urged him to seize the hostilities
and emphasize that russia must ensure
rapid safe and unimpeded humanitarian
access to the civilian population
particularly in mario paul he stressed
also the need to find a negotiated
solution to end the war
president the suffering is widespread
russia's war is causing the largest
humanitarian crisis in europe since the
second world war
a quarter of the ukrainian population
has now been displaced
and cluster munition will continue to
maim and kill long after the conflict
has ended
the reconstruction
when it comes will take years
ukraine has been set back decades in its
economic development
and the consequences of this war will be
felt by generation of ukrainians
russia's war is also being felt globally
exacerbating other humanitarian crises
and causing a serious negative effect on
the agricultural sector with a global
rise in food ensue security and
increased prices of fuel and fertilizers
president before concluded
concluding let me be very clear much
russia must abide by international law
it must comply with the order of the
international court of justice to
immediately suspend this military
operation
and to withdraw its troop from ukraine
the killing and destruction must end
russia must stop its illegal war thank
you
representative of norway for her
statement and i now give the floor to
the representative of ghana
thank you very much madam president i
congratulate the uae for its successful
presidency in the preceding month and
wish you
and the uk delegation the very best for
this month
let me begin by thanking secretary
general the secretary general for his
statements of the council
and welcoming the briefings of usg
rosemary dicarlo
and usg and emergency relief coordinator
martin griffins
on the prevailing situation ukraine and
the coordinated humanitarian response
of the united nations agencies
in the face of difficult operational
challenges on the ground
i also welcome the virtual participation
in this meeting of the president of
ukraine his excellency
mr
vladimir zelinski
my delegation has taken careful note of
the ukrainian president's remark
noted his country's steadfast commitment
to peace
and encourage the path of dialogue and
diplomacy in finding a settlement of
this needless war
madame president the prolongation of the
war in ukraine continues to be a
situation of deep concern for ghana
we are particularly disturbed by the
increasing humanitarian costs arising
from the unjustified
aggression by the russian federation
against ukraine
we have observed with pained and riddled
bombardment
of civilian populated areas as well as
civilian and other critical
infrastructure
without regard to the customary norms of
international law and the principles of
international humanitarian law
relating to armed conflict
ghana is gravely concerned by the
reports of alleged cross violations of
international humanitarian law
and international criminal law since the
onset of the invasion
including emerging reports and images of
human rights violations and the killings
of civilians
in barrier pool
and areas on the outskirts of kiev such
as butcher
we support the call by the secretary
general for an independent impartial
and torah investigations to establish
the facts gather the evidence
and to hold all perpetrators of such
atrocious crimes accountable
for their actions
the killing of children the aged
medical personnel humanitarian workers
and journalists are deplorable
and we condemn all such acts
unreservedly
we add restraint on all sides and
re-emphasize the urgency
of an unconditional cessation of
hostilities nationwide
to enable the evacuation and safe
passage of civilians
and facilitate the delivery of
life-saving aid to the people in the
cities that remain under siege
humanitarian agencies require
unobstructed access to rich people in
need of food water and medicine and
other critical supplies
and all parties must guarantee such
access
the ravages of both the global covet 19
pandemic
and the situation ukraine demonstrates
the intercoordinatedness and
interdependence of states
and reinforce the need for a unified
international response in support of the
path of dialogue
and diplomacy
madam president we have followed closely
the direct negotiations between the
conflicting parties
and note the progress made in the
forefront of consultations which took
place in istanbul on 29th of march 2022
to sustain the negotiations we urge a
restraint in the ongoing hostilities
and the follow through of the express
commitments to resolve the security
concerns of the parties
in fragrance of the efforts of the
parties the council met at this time
focused attention
on supporting confidence-building
measures that facilitated negotiated
settlement of the immediate conflict
and the wider question of european
security on the basis of international
law
and other internationally agreed
frameworks
the convergence of the parties and the
international community on these matters
will be the only way to end the tensions
bridge the differences between the
parties and forge a unified
position on the situation in ukraine i
thank you for your kind attention
i thank the representative of ghana for
his statement and i now give the floor
to
the representative of the united arab
emirates
thank you madam president and i'd like
to join others in congratulating you and
your team for assuming uh the presidency
and wishing you a productive month i'd
also like to thank
the secretary general the under
secretary general for political and
peace building affairs and the under
secretary general for humanitarian
affairs and the emergency relief
coordinator for their helpful briefings
we also thank president zielenski for
his address to this council
we have once again heard in this council
deeply sobering and concerning reports
from the ground including from martin
griffiths and rosemary de carlo and with
every meeting the council is reminded of
the rapidly deteriorating humanitarian
situation on the ground in ukraine one
quarter of the country's population have
fled their homes and the rising death
toll and the destruction of critical
civilian infrastructure are a grim
reflection of the tragic human cost of
war
the images coming out of bucha and other
towns and cities are shocking
the alleged crimes they entail are of
the utmost gravity and first and
foremost as others have said we must
establish what has happened here with
the cooperation of all parties
it is imperative that we do not get
caught up in a war of narratives in
addition to the conflict that is ongoing
indeed we need to allow for the existing
mechanisms to investigate the facts on
the ground impartially so that justice
for all victims can be served and we
acknowledge the secretary general's call
for that independent
investigation as well as last week's
appointment of the members of the human
rights council's independent
international commission of inquiry on
ukraine
as we enter the sixth week of conflict
we believe that an immediate cessation
of hostilities throughout ukraine is
imperative
to move towards a peaceful solution to
the war in ukraine and we take note of
efforts to reach a diplomatic resolution
to the conflict and we see the ongoing
negotiations and several rounds of
negotiations between russia and ukraine
as a very positive development
we remain hopeful that these efforts at
the negotiating table can urgently
translate into de-escalation on the
ground and we urge others to support
these efforts
we also welcome the readout from mr
griffiths on his meetings with senior
russian officials as well as his
upcoming meetings with ukrainian
officials establishing a
viable humanitarian ceasefire could be a
stepping stone for broader negotiations
and eventually a sustainable peace
however until their cessation of
hostilities is achieved the priority
must be to work towards protecting and
alleviating the suffering of civilians
and in addition to the points we made
during the last council meeting on
ukraine on 29th march i want to focus
here on four additional points for the
council's consideration
first as others have done we all need to
continue to reaffirm uh the need for all
parties to abide by their obligations
under international humanitarian law in
particular the protection of civilians
and the respect for the principles of
distinction and proportionality that are
paramount in conflict
second the difficulties in providing
relief and humanitarian access need to
be addressed immediately and can be
addressed quickly
it's critical to find either local or
broad-based agreements for security
guarantees to allow for the safe
provision of humanitarian assistance and
for civilians to voluntarily evacuate
safely and these are initial
confidence-building measures that can be
developed down the line and should also
be encouraged including the proposals
left by mr griffiths with the government
in moscow
third as the icrc has noted
false narratives and disinformation
has the potential to cause real harm for
humanitarian organizations on the ground
the use of digital technologies that
amplify the spread of harmful
information including misinformation
disinformation and hate speech is a true
challenge in conflict zones and these
phenomena are not new
but technology has greatly increased the
scale and speed at which harmful
information reaches target audiences
online and this is particularly
concerning in crisis settings where
information can influence the dynamics
and behavior on the ground and can put
communities and humanitarian responders
at risk
fourth
at a time of conflict protecting
civilians of course must be our top
priority however we should not forget
the impact that war has on a nation's
cultural heritage and identity
we're concerned by unesco's recent
reports on the dozens of cultural sites
that have been damaged in ukraine since
the conflict began
we know from our experience in the
middle east that protection of cultural
sites is critical to rebuilding peace
and in moments of violence and turmoil
cultural sites are essential
cornerstones for collective memory and
the foundation for future reconciliation
we therefore call on all parties to
refrain from the unlawful destruction of
cultural heritage and to think about
what comes next after the war concludes
for the people living there and how they
go about building peace
before i end allow me to take a moment
to reflect on
what others have commented on including
the secretary general and that is the
devastating impact of the conflict on
food security worldwide and we're
alarmed by these figures shared by the
secretary general just now on how the
war is affecting some of the most
vulnerable communities around the world
1.2 billion people in 47 developing
countries are at risk due to rising food
prices and food shortages are
aggravating situations already on this
council's agenda and these shortages are
felt in other settings where high prices
of basic commodities can lead to further
unrest and instability not just in this
part of the world but around the globe
so we look forward to seeing the un
global crisis response group on food
energy and finance address these issues
and offer it our full support
and let us not forget that the effects
of this war are hitting communities that
are still reeling from the global coven
19 pandemic and these vulnerabilities
are further exacerbated by reduced
domestic food production due to the
rising costs and scarcity of chemical
fertilizers and pesticides and the
knock-on effects including global
conflicts will be grave and the council
must stay focused on all of them unless
we do something to end this conflict now
it will continue to drive suffering and
instability worldwide in the coming
months and years and the world simply
cannot afford this
and the security council should do its
part to stop this conflict and to help
parties come and reach a peaceful
solution thank you
i thank the representative of the united
arab emirates for her statement
and i will now make a statement in my
capacity as the representative of the
united kingdom
president zielenski
by video secretary general colleagues
the united nations was created
in the wake of a european war of
aggression
that laid waste to europe and engulfed
the world
all of us
who signed the un charter
committed to ending the scourge of war
to fundamental human rights
the dignity and worth of the human
person
the equal rights of nations large and
small
to justice and respect
for international law
yet now
we're facing another war of aggression
in europe
we've heard today
again
the devastating impact of russia's
unilateral and illegal military action
in ukraine
its impact on surrounding countries and
the region
and on the security and prosperity of
the wider world
as it seeks to recover from the covet 19
pandemic
thousands killed
millions displaced
cities raised to the ground
hospitals bombed
citizens cut off from food water and
medicine
blockaded seaports
and the rapid increase in wheat prices
pressure
on already stretched humanitarian
resources
and now
as russia is forced into retreat from
areas around kiev
the brutality of the invasion is laid
bare
we've all seen the horrific images
from the towns of butcher and elpine
of civilians deliberately killed in
areas
from which russian forces have we
recently withdrawn
and the video we saw earlier
underlined that horror
these acts
and other credible incidents
must be investigated as war crimes
and the uk fully supports the work of
the international criminal court
and the work of the ukrainian prosecutor
general
and other national prosecutors
colleagues
as we and so many others have said so
many times
all of this could be stopped
if the russian federation ended this war
now
i resume my function as president of the
council
the representative of the russian
federation has asked for the floor
to make a further statement
thank you madam president
i know that this is not bringing us
closer to the end of today's meeting but
since today's topic is extremely
important
i think it's
essential essentials
to
say a few words about what was the
reason for this meeting which we didn't
have a chance to say yesterday because
we were not given a chance to have a
separate meeting of the security council
on this topic
unfortunately
um
any way possible
our western colleagues tried to to kind
of uh
sweep it under the carpet and we have
seen
an example of how of the new order based
new rules based orders based on
for conducting today's meeting
and
led to some far-reaching conclusions
that many of you have already made
it
all units of the russian armed forces
fully withdrew from
as a gesture of good faith on the 30th
of march
after uh a
round of negotiations between russia and
ukraine in turkey
negotiators
now a report about this was published
that very same day on an official
website of the russians
during the time that the town was under
the control of the russian armed forces
a single civilian suffered from any kind
of violence
the um the russian army
supplied 450
450 tons of humanitarian assistance to
those cities this is these things
now the
the towns the russian army did not
prevent people from leaving the towns
the towns uh toward the north
at the same time
the southern the southern areas
including
ukrainian forces
from using uh heavy caliber weapons
tanks and mortars
already after the withdrawal of the
russian forces
the mayor of buchanan
video statement on the 31st of march
liberation of the city by the ukrainian
any local inhabitants with their hands
tied having been shot
i mean could you believe that the mayor
would not have noticed on the streets
as reported of 280 corpses
on the first of april deputy of the
council
ukrainian security forces have entered
the town and are conducting a mop-up
operation
and she is asking she's asking everyone
to be very careful
on social media you can also find an
almost
minute
there are no bodies of civilians
local residents who didn't mention any
corpses or
guilt
the russian army is being accused of
some kind of
man
we could not notice how uh
and the official facts is clear
if the courts
have been out of the ocean
signs
don't seem to be bothered by that
new york times
to shoot anyone who doesn't have blue
arm uh
a member of the territorial
uh
ukrainian uh armed forces that are
guilty of most of them
these are details that have not uh been
mentioned in the uh presentations of our
western and ukrainian colleagues
ukrainians the right for an uncivilized
response
based on how ukrainian radicals behaved
in the east
coast
and staging do not intend to stop there
based on his confirmed information in
the evening
of april april in the town of moshoon
three kilometers
is
these kinds
uh
we are
russian
soldiers and to present them as
murderers and rapists
i said once again that this is an
incredibly low blow
problem
today already already the ukraine is
full
of uh
in fact
uh
information refuting what was in the
video that stating that it wasn't
filmed in the right place with not the
right
that it had the audacity of condemning
the actions of american soldiers in
afghanistan
this is well known the
united states left the council
organization
in the united nations
washington and it's very dangerous uh
games thank you very much
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement
the representative of ukraine has asked
for the floor to make a further
statement
well thank you madam president
before i switch to english i would say a
couple of words a couple of lines rather
in russian
[Music]
is
and then after uh after lowering these
rations they uh tossed their names
you wanted to quote that interview why
didn't you quote the whole interview
this is about your humanity
now let me switch to english
i would like to make my further
statement in response to the
hypocritical questions
by putin's representative
after the video we
so with the shocking images from butcher
european
material
and other sites
he should ask these very
questions to himself
how have russians got to the cruelty of
nazis
when have you started enjoying acting
like
nazis
killing civilians
attempting to withdraw internationally
recognized borders
setting the task to
finalize finally resolve the ukrainian
issue
like hitler attempted to resolve the
jewish issue
when did you miss the point of russia's
turning into the nazi-style cancerous
tumor
unable and unwilling to stop expanding
and bringing
to neighboring nations sufferings
destruction
pain and death
i'm appalled over york cynical and
outright lie that you don't hate
civilian targets
and that is why you're moving so slowly
you hit the civilian targets and you
kill the civilians
shall i quote your own words of
yesterday in the press conference that
you gave here in the headquarters
where you said that civilians are killed
by your army
or shall i not
should i play the video
you said is this war
civilians are killed in the war
it's a warfare you said
or perhaps your mindset in your mindset
a children's hospital in micholiev
destroyed by the russian strike
yesterday was a military target
and perhaps a child killed as a result
of the strike was a ukrainian
nationalist
the only truth you've said is that you
are not moving as planned
and the only reason
is the resistance of the ukrainian army
and the ukrainian people
not your smart military planning
the ukrainian people who realize
quite clear
what the russian world in reality means
and we thank the international community
for the solidarity with ukraine
ukraine will win
in its territory
and the entire world will win despite
the threats
that the criminal and the liar throws in
the face just in the security council
chamber
finally
if there is anything that we have to
thank the russian representative for
it is his acknowledgment
at the yesterday's press conference
that russia is waging war against
ukraine war you said several times
not the special operation
and i consider this confession
shall impact the u.n assessment
of what is going on in the center of
europe
perhaps it was the unique movement
when we should believe
what a fully accredited representative
says in the united nations
hence once again
a reminder
to putin's diplomats
ribbon trop denied
any knowledge
of concentration camps
racial examination policies
yet was found guilty at nuremberg war
crime
trial
and we all know what happened to him on
the 16th of october 1946.
thank you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for his statement
i now give the floor to his excellency
mr olof skoog the head of delegation of
the european union to the united nations
thank you madam president i addressed
the security council on behalf of the
european union and its member states
north macedonia montenegro and albania
bosnia and herzegovina iceland and
liechtenstein republic of moldova
georgia monaco and san marino all
aligned themselves with this statement
and i want to start by congratulating
you
uh madam madam president for the united
kingdom for assuming the presidency for
the month of april and for convening
this meeting and for inviting us to
speak and also acknowledge the
presidency of march of the united arab
emirates
i want to thank the secretary-general
this under secretary general dicarlo and
griffiths for their presentations and i
want to express our full support
solidarity and respect for the heroic
people of ukraine as embodied by the
message this morning by president
silenski
madam president 41 days ago russia
decided to wage a war of aggression
against ukraine in blatant violation of
international law the principles of the
un charter and of the key of the osce an
affront to the rules-based order
and to the global security instability
and we have heard and seen again today
the tremendous cost to the people of
ukraine
the dramatic consequences of russia's
war of choice are well known thousands
of life have been have been lost
over 11 million people most of them
women and children have been forced to
leave their homes over 500 schools and
52 hospitals have been shelled entire
cities have been raised to the ground
the unfolding drama in mario paul and
the images from bucha stain our common
humanity russia must stop this senseless
act of violence
the eu condemns in the strongest terms
russia's unjustified an unprovoked war
of aggression against ukraine we demand
that russia immediately stop its
military aggression immediately and
unconditionally withdrawal forces from
the entire territory of ukraine and
fully respect ukraine's territorial
integrity sovereignty and independence
within its internationally recognized
borders as demanded by the united
nations general assembly
we condemn in the strongest possible
terms the reported atrocities committed
by the russian armed forces in a number
of occupied ukrainian towns
haunting images of massacres with large
numbers of civilian deaths and
casualties as well as destruction of
civilian infrastructure show the true
face of russia's brutal war of
aggression
these massacres will be inscribed in the
list of atrocities committed by russia
on european soil
the russian authorities are responsible
for these crimes committed while they
had effective control of the area
they are subject to the international
law of occupation
russia is directing attacks against the
civilian population and is targeting
civilian objects including hospitals
medical facilities schools and shelters
these war crimes must stop immediately
those responsible will be held to
account in accordance with international
law
we welcome the international court of
justice's provisional measures ordering
russia to suspend military operations
immediately
we fully support the investigation
launched by the prosecutor of the
international criminal court into war
crimes and crimes against humanity as
well as the work of the independent
commission of inquiry
the eu is assisting the ukrainian
prosecutor general and civil society in
the collection and preservation of
evidence of the war crimes
it is clear there must be and there will
be accountability
the uns member states are providing
shelter for the more than four million
refugees that fled russia's violence
they do so regardless of nationality
ethnicity religion or race
we have adopted sanctions against the
russian government its financial and
defense sectors and those individuals
enabling and financing the aggression
we have committed significant funding to
the u.n humanitarian flash appeal and
regional refugee response plans for
ukraine
so far the eu and its member states have
mobilized over 1.1 billion euros in
emergency aid
this comes on top of the 2.4 million
euros in humanitarian emergency and
early recovery assistance the eu and its
member states have provided to ukraine
since 2014.
in the largest ever operation under the
eu civil protection mechanism 29
countries all eu member states together
with norway and turkey have responded to
the request for assistance from ukraine
as the 4th of april over 13 000 tons of
medicines hospital equipment ambulances
and firefighting equipment food and
energy supplies have arrived in ukraine
european leaders have set up a ukraine
solidarity trust fund to channel support
to post-war post-war reconstruction
and at the pledging event on 9th of
april with canada we will further
showcase that we stand in words and
deeds with the courageous people of
ukraine
madam president after the security
council was unable to take action
the general assembly demonstrated once
again less than two weeks ago the
overwhelming international rejection of
the russian aggression and an
overwhelming support to addressing the
humanitarian crisis in ukraine
the international community demanded
safe and unhindered passage for civil
civilians fleeing violence as well as
humanitarian access to those in need
international humanitarian law must be
respected
the dramatic consequences of russia's
war against ukraine are not limited to
europe they are global
ukrainian farmers are prevented from
sowing as a result of russian shelling
ships filled with wheat and are blocked
in black sea ports by russian military
forces as a result food prices have
rocketed pushing people into poverty and
threatening to destabilize entire
regions the poorest countries as we've
heard are the most vulnerable to shocks
in food prices all this is a direct
result of the war despite russia's
cynical attempts to shift the blame
madam president the eu
and its member states are fully
mobilized to end the war in line with
international law and the u.n charter
but at the same time crisis the world
over need our urgent attention the eu
will continue to provide humanitarian
and development support to our partner
countries from north africa to the
middle east and from sub-saharan africa
to asia
we are scaling up our multilateral
action to provide support to countries
with acute food insecurity and are
committed to keeping global trade routes
open so agricultural staples can feed
the world the eu has pledged 2.5 billion
euros for international cooperation
related to nutrition for the period
2021-2024
we also fully support the work of the un
to deliver and scaling up humanitarian
assistance protect refugees and work
towards the ceasefire
with the particular focus on food
security
we will contribute to the work of the
global crisis response group to deal
with the global social and economic
effects of the war we heard your
recommendations this morning sector
journal and we have already launched a
strategy for safeguarding food security
in reinforcing the resilience of food
systems backed by increased assistance
madam president
once again we call on russia to cease
the destruction of innocent life across
ukraine and immediately and
unconditionally withdraw all its troops
we call for an immediate ceasefire safe
passage to civilians trapped in war
zones and uninterrupted humanitarian
access
we stand in solidarity with the people
of ukraine and all other people affected
by the war of russian aggression
we stand in support of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and we will continue to work diligently
with the un and our partners to end this
aggression and address the humanitarian
needs i thank you madam president
i thank his excellency mr skoog for his
statement i also acknowledge the written
statements submitted by the delegation
of poland
in earlier before the meeting and also
from the eight nordic baltic countries
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
down
oh
so
what
yes
so
foreign
uh
yes
so
so
good afternoon i'm going to make these
remarks in my national capacity as the
permanent representative of the united
kingdom
the security council has just met to
discuss
russia's continued assault on ukraine
40 days into the war
including the harrowing images and
reports that came out of butcher at the
weekend
president zielenski also addressed the
council following his visit to butcher
yesterday
president zielenski's reports
of the destruction and torture russian
soldiers carried out on ukrainian
civilians
were extremely harrowing
he told us
about the men and women
who were shot in the streets
with their hands tied behind their backs
he told us that women had been gang
raped
including in front of their children
that people had had their limbs cut off
and their tongues cut out
that russian tanks
had crushed ukrainian families
who sat in their cars
unable to escape
he told us
that there must be accountability for
these crimes
the uk
as current president of the council and
as a committed partner of ukraine
will not rest until that has happened
and you'll remember that we support we
were the early supporters of the icc
inquiry which is now going on and we
welcome the announcement today from the
secretary general of an independent
inquiry
frankly we found russia blamed everyone
else
but we've all seen the satellite images
that show the bodies having been in
butcher for weeks
president zielenski also called
for the united nations the un security
council
and the international architecture
to act
on these war crimes
and
to reform if necessary
the united nations was also clear
11.3 million people have now been
displaced
so we do need to investigate these
crimes
and in his remarks
the secretary general set out the global
consequences
rising food prices
more than 50 developing countries
with more than 1.2 billion people
affected by the ripple effects of this
war
we need to silence the guns we're all
clear about that
thank you
president zielinski do you agree with
him on the statement when he said that
there is security council but there is
no peace in the world and he even asked
to remove russia from the security
council or to reconsider the mechanism
of how the united nation and security
council work do you agree with this
statement
i think it's true that the security
council was set up to protect peace and
security in the world
and in the light of russia's veto
we have been very restricted in our
ability to act i think it's very welcome
that we've seen the general assembly act
so decisively both to condemn russia's
invasion of ukraine and also to call for
humanitarian support and we've seen that
in those strong votes that you've seen
with 141 and 140 countries but we do
need to make sure that now and in the
future the security council and the u.n
as a whole is able to respond to these
sort of challenges and that's why we're
very strong supporters of the secretary
general's common agenda which will help
drive through these reforms we need to
see
thank you madam ambassador uh there
seems to be a unanimous call for an
independent investigation not only
ambucha but elsewhere in ukraine can you
perhaps talk about how soon that can
happen and what the process is in that
regard
well the secretary general announced
today
that he had asked for an independent
inquiry but we know that karim khan the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court is already in ukraine and his team
is already in the business of collecting
evidence and that's a very uh
sophisticated and important part of this
so we very much welcome those
developments thank you
so
huh
there's a pile of bloody lies
nothing new
that's a clear desire to twist the
situation
and the reality and as my president said
on several occasions we are
for the full uh independent
investigation
we are not living in the 18th 19th 20th
century we are living in the 21st
century where we have
multiple high-tech means to verify the
facts including the satellite forensics
and all other things
ambassador president zaleski failed the
u.s security council for preventing
the war in ukraine but elsewhere and he
has given some examples syria
afghanistan and he called for a fair
representation can anyone start or can
they start questioning the role of
russia and how can they do it well the
role of russia is unquestionable it's a
disastrous i mean that's a clear and a
very effective immobilizer
of uh on the way of fulfillment by the
security council of the mandate
so there is a need and i think that
one of the outcomes of this tragedy of
this ball should be
a real and serious revision
of the way
the security council functions and if
the entire international community it's
not only about ukraine it's about the
entire international community if the
entire international community can trust
the security council as it is today
with the security
you know so there will be no switching
to business as usual
or if there is a switching to the
business as usual
then
as my president said these organizations
should dissolve itself
the russian ambassadors just told me
that the video that was just played that
is all fake as well
what can i say
of course it's fake
russian mind it is but as i said i can't
i bring you back to my reply to the
first question but how do you counter
the constant i will not dignify
the bunch and the torrent of lies
it is not my job
to investigate and to verify ukraine is
open to international investigation all
right
there's there are already satellite
imagery
satellites can read your text messages
to your family on your smartphone you
know so satellites are able to do
everything
was that what should be the next step
will be
the consideration of suspension of the
human rights council membership of the
russian federation which is an appalling
tumor on the human rights council using
the language of
it's not the alternative security i i'm
not sure that your
quoting proper we can properly we can
refer to the actual text but
the current security architecture as it
stands
is not capable
to guarantee and provide security that's
a matter of fact and you cannot deny it
so we must revisit
the architecture and we have to be
responsible in setting up something that
provides security to a caribbean nation
to an african nation to a latin american
nation to a european nation which
happens unfortunately so far to be a
neighbor to to the russian federation
all right
in the coming days
no it's a very comprehensive subject
that should be
discussed thoroughly
but the discussion should not be a
repetition of a marathon
a september marathon in the general
assembly it should be
a very thorough discussion after the war
vote do you have a date on that no we
don't have a date we are working with
the office of the pga we are working
with the secretary to the general
assembly as well we are in the process
of consultations with many countries
we will not do it uh single-handedly
we're not doing on our own it's on our
own or with the minimum amount number of
countries that will be across regional
action all right
yes
come on
[Music]